[Music]
straight ahead on Long crime daily the
Parkland school shooter penalty phase
trial Nicholas just didn't have
the social skills Witnesses give a
closer look at the gunman's childhood
and you said that it was consistent with
a traumatic event involving the neck and
face at or around the time
with that correct here forensic
anthropologist expert testimony as an
Ohio man stands trial for murder plus
opening statements are presented in
Florida versus Trevor Summers Elisa
Summers while her hands are tied she's
able to stop it
as he is trying to pull that rope and
strangle her around her neck gather the
facts put the facts together with the
law make a conclusion if a crime was
committed what crime that will and later
the federal trial of R Kelly a mother
confesses she was scared for her life
after being threatened by the singer
long crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long crime daily
I'm your host Allison Hall in for Brian
buckmeyer as the defense continues its
case in the Parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial Focus shifts from
the gunman's biological mother to his
adoptive mother in February 2018 a then
19 year old gunman opened fire at
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School in
Broward County Florida 17 people were
killed and 17 more were injured in
October of last year the gunman pleaded
guilty to all charges it's now up to a
Broward County jury to determine whether
he receives life in prison or is
sentenced to death the defense began its
case on Monday presenting an opening
statement attorneys highlighted the
difficult upbringing the defendant had
including a biological mother who
continued to use drugs and alcohol while
pregnant on Tuesday testimony shifted to
the defendant's adoptive mother Linda
Cruz who died several months before the
shooting a close friend described
Developmental and social delays in the
defendant's early years saying his
adoptive mother did not want to seek
treatment
did his lack of development and some of
his behavior concern you
yes okay so
what did you do with your concerns
well
as a mother you don't want to go and
tell another mother but she was my
friend
and so it actually first came up
that Roger noticed it because Roger had
four children and grandchildren and he
had brought it up at my home
he wanted to Linda to bring him to like
a specialist and stuff
Linda didn't see anything wrong
she didn't want she didn't want to see
anything wrong with him
That's Not Unusual no it's not okay
and when you would try to have these
conversations with her was she receptive
no
joining us today is co-host Harry Austin
and Los Angeles County Deputy public
defender Philip Dubay Phillip let's
start with you here the defendant has
admitted to all of these charges plus of
course 18 sorry 17 people were killed do
you think despite the defendant's
difficult childhood the jury would
actually decide in favor of the death
penalty
well Allison it's a very subjective
approach despite the expose of this
troubled kids childhood in utero
exposure to intoxicants and drugs
alcohol and despite the special needs
that he had in the school system and how
Mom the education system and the system
in general failed him 12 jurors are left
with a very subjective balancing
approach to decide if all the
aggravating facts surrounding this case
outweigh that traumatic mitigation is
there a chance of course but I believe
that on this evidence the aggravating
factors are weighted much more heavily
against the mitigation but he only needs
one juror to find that the aggravators
Do Not outweigh the mitigators and if so
he gets life without parole
and Terry the defendant's biological
mother was a drug addict then he lost
his adoptive mother three months before
the shooting do you think that the loss
of his adopted mother further impacted
this defendant
Allison I definitely think so when he
lost his adopted mother it was only a
couple of months later that the shooting
occurred it definitely contributed to
his downfall no family is perfect Linda
and her husband Roger they definitely
provided some stability both financial
and emotional and even though Linda did
not want to recognize the problems that
Nicholas Cruz had she eventually got him
the help he needed so it definitely hurt
him
we'll certainly be following along with
his penalty phase trial as it continues
let's Head West now to Northern
California where we're hearing from the
dive team that recovered the body of
Kylie Rodney the 16 year old was last
seen on August 6th at a party near Lake
Tahoe she texted her mother that she
would soon return home but never arrived
her 2013 Honda CRV was also missing on
Sunday the oregon-based rescue team
adventures with purpose announced on its
Facebook page that Rodney's body was
found in the overturned SUV on Monday
California law enforcement confirmed the
vehicle inside the water was Rodney's
and on Tuesday confirmed the remains
were also hers so far Rodney's manner of
death has not been released and the
investigation is still ongoing lawn
crime networks spoke with the diver who
recovered the vehicle and body he
explains what it was like to make that
discovery
there's a obviously a split second of
disappointment because that's not what
you that's not how you wanted this story
to end but at the same time
it's also uh finally some answers to The
Disappearance of the missing person
and then you have to kind of mentally
prepare yourself to go down and do the
vehicle assessment to continue your task
at hand to you know take notes of as to
the condition of the vehicle if the
windows are up down is the vehicle
damaged is there anything inside it
um is there remains inside it and that
sort of thing so it's uh yeah there's a
few moments there where emotionally you
have to kind of hold it together and
just keep focused at the task at hand
still ahead on Long crime daily opening
statements are presented in the trial of
Florida versus Trevor Summers but first
the death of Emily Noble forensic
experts explain the condition of her
body when it was discovered in the woods
[Music]
welcome back heading now to Ohio where
jurors hear from an anthropologist
involved in the investigation into the
alleged staged suicide of Emily Noble as
her husband Matthew Moore stands trial
for her murder Moore reported his wife
missing after her 52nd birthday in May
2020 volunteer search parties looked for
Noble over the next few months though
more reportedly never helped in the
search in mid-september a group of three
women found Noble's body in a wooded
area near the couple's home with a USB
cord wrapped around her neck her body
was so badly decomposed investigators
had to use dental records and DNA to
confirm her identity investigators say
her death was staged to look like a
suicide the following June Moore was
arrested and charged with her murder Dr
Amanda Agnew examined the remains after
Noble's body was found
all of the Blue Area arrows are
indicating
locations where a fracture was
identified that was antimortem so there
was evidence of healing the red arrow is
indicating a location of perimortem
trauma
um so again it has those Jagged edges
that can be seen there and there's no
indication of healing the bioprofile
indicated a middle adult female of
European ancestry
that sustained perimortem trauma to the
neck and face as well as had evidence of
antimordum trauma
and some minor systemic reactions in the
bone throughout the skeleton
and so specifically with regard to the
Paranormal trauma you said that it was
consistent with a traumatic event
involving the neck and face at or around
the time of death
correct
Terry let's start with you the body of
the victim was severely decomposed do
you think that the prosecution could
argue that Moore did not participate in
the search because he did not want his
wife's body to be found
listen if I were the prosecution I would
definitely make that argument most
spouses will participate in the search
of their missing partner so you have to
imagine that maybe he doesn't want his
wife to be found I think it's very odd
that he did not help if he in fact
killed his wife he could leave her out
there they could make sure that the body
was decomposed at that point he could
make sure that there's less evidence
less DNA and so I think it would be much
more difficult to determine the cause
and manner of death at that point so if
I were the prosecution I would
definitely argue that and Philip the
doctor's testimony describes facial
injuries but couldn't the defense argue
that those injuries occurred during the
hanging if it was suicide
well the only way they're going to be
able to do that effectively is with an
expert typically the human tissue the
Derma the viscera they will pre-mortem
and even postmortem just sort of malform
and mouth shape and maybe even slip away
from skeletal remains but the skeleton
itself remains intact unless there is
some type of blunt force trauma
inflicted pre-mortem or perhaps during
the quote-unquote suicide or after death
it is very unlikely that an animal from
the Fauna of that region would have
inflicted that type of harm because that
type of velocity would have pulled the
body down and would have been on the
ground it's not as if you know not to
sound crass if somebody was trying to
hit a pinata to break it open the whole
thing would have collapsed but it was in
fact found hanging so it's very unlikely
Thank You Phillip coming up on Long
crime daily it's week two of testimony
in federal court where R Kelly stands
trial for a string of sex crimes plus
your opening statements from both sides
as a Florida man stands trial for
attempted murder
foreign
[Music]
welcome back opening statements are
presented in the Florida trial of Trevor
Summers as he faces charges for the 2017
attempted murder sexual assault and
kidnapping of his estranged wife Elisa
Mathewson the incident began Friday
March 10th of that year after months of
conflict between the couple the
September before Summers had pleaded
guilty to federal fraud charges and was
awaiting sentencing a few months later
amid divorce proceedings a judge barred
the couple from seeing each other but
Summers allegedly told their then 14
year old daughter he wanted to reconcile
and he needed some alone time with his
wife authorities say Summers had planned
a murder-suicide and had convinced his
children into letting him into
mathewson's house over the next three
days Summers allegedly held matthewson
captive in her home and the back seat of
her SUV prosecutors say he attempted to
kill her twice once with a pillow and
again later with a rope it all came to
an end when witness a witness saw the
SUV and followed them leading to finding
matthewson and the arrest of Summers
prosecutors explained in their opening
statement Tuesday that Summers confessed
to what happened that weekend
he writes letters
in the back of the victim's vehicle
letters that you will get to see a
confession letter
of what took place on March 11 2017 at
her home
writes a surrender of his parental
rights
writes letters that Miss Summers is to
get his car the money in his bank
account and his home
and a letter that he wrote to his
children
a letter that he wrote before the second
attempted homicide incident
you will get to see that letter you will
get to make the determination what kind
of letter that was
Summers defense attorney argued there
was no motive behind the allegations
against his client telling the jury they
will have to decide if what actually
happened was a crime
you're going to leave with a feeling of
despair
in hearing this very tragic story about
a family that fell apart the story that
Miss Johnson gave you is a story
it is the state's Theory of what
happened there were times she she says
the testimony
from Mrs Summers will be that she was
tied up that she couldn't get away that
she was forced that she had no
alternative when you get to the sexual
assault you have to make some decisions
about the distinctions between consent
and acquiescence
most certainly an individual who is
being abducted
and decides to do anything this day a
lot
that would be acquiescence and I would
agree that that's not that's not consent
but the question is is that the
situation in this case
Philip this case boils down to a he said
she said but if the children testify and
support their mother's version do you
think that will be enough for a
conviction
oh Allison attempt crimes are some of
the most difficult to defend because
obviously your victim lives long enough
to testify against the defendant in this
particular case the defense is going to
have to show a darn good reason why the
kids would lie why would they make this
up were they alienated against him by
the mother was their family had it who
had it in for him and just are doing
whatever they can to take him down but
moreover did the kids give prior
inconsistent statements perhaps to the
police or family members or neighbors
and moreover were any of uh the wife's
injuries if any consistent with how the
kids say they were how they went down if
you will how they were inflicted how she
even got them but short of that I think
it is a tall order for uh for this
defendant indeed it is and Terry during
opening statements defense counsel told
the jury that they could decide the
child neglect neglect charges for
themselves do you think that's the
defendant conceding that charge
it sure sounded as though he were
conceding it listen the fact that those
children were left alone and the 14 year
old drove 25 miles by herself and the
three-year-old was alone all of that
under Florida law certainly could add up
to child neglect because it doesn't show
that there is a reasonable care of
someone who is in your welfare
right it's certainly a heartbreaking
story and we'll continue following along
as it develops when we come back we head
to Illinois for the federal trial of
singer R Kelly why the mother of an
alleged victim says she lied to a grand
jury about Kelly's abuse
welcome back the defense presented their
closing argument late Tuesday afternoon
in Vanessa Bryant's Los Angeles lawsuit
as she sues the county over photos taken
at the crash site where her husband and
daughter died the 2020 helicopter crash
killed Vanessa's husband Kobe Bryant
their daughter Gianna and seven others
the lawsuit claims close-up photos were
taken of their remains and that those
photos were distributed among First
Responders and even shared with members
of the public on several occasions
Bryant says this caused emotional
distress and violated their family's
privacy Tuesday Morning jurors heard the
final moment of testimony from the
acting chief of the LA County Fire
Department he said he didn't know the
now retired Captain who photographed
remains at the site and that he never
instructed him to take photos opposite
of what the captain testified last week
several planned expert Witnesses didn't
end up testifying including a
psychiatrist aimed at explaining the
plaintiff's emotional state once the
defense rested Tuesday afternoon the
judge decided not to wait until
Wednesday to start closing arguments so
far there's been no indication as to the
amount the plaintiffs are seeking also
in Celebrity legal news a mother
testifies her family feared for their
lives after a tense meeting with R B
singer R Kelly more than two decades ago
this comes as the 55 year old convicted
sex offender stance trial in Illinois
for 13 Federal sex crime charges back in
2008 Kelly was acquitted by a Cook
County Illinois jury for creating a
video of himself having sex with a 14
year old girl at the time the girl and
her parents denied involvement and did
not testify now the alleged victim's
mother says her family lied to a grand
jury out of fear for their safety the
woman using the pseudonym Susan says she
was threatened by Kelly in the year
2000. she told jurors quote we feared
for our lives and we were intimidated
and we just wanted to make sure my
daughter was safe her daughter using the
name Jane testified last week she told
jurors she was the 14 year old girl
shown in the explicit video and that she
had sex with Kelly hundreds of times
while underage
Philip let's start with you here Kelly
faces additional State charges in
Illinois and Minnesota do you think he
should try to reach a universal plea
deal resolving all of these charges
oh that's a tough question Allison I
think a lot of it hinges on what some of
the pre-trial and the what I call the in
lemonade rulings are in that Illinois
courtroom so for example is the judge
going to allow evidence of all the
federal conduct for which he was
recently convicted into evidence in the
State Trial if that comes in that could
be so unduly prejudicial that the jury
won't believe the defense now on the
other hand you have complaining
Witnesses here who are ready willing and
able to take the stand and tell the jury
what R Kelly did to them years ago but
on the flip side of that they also lied
to a similar body of jurors who heard
evidence from them under oath that it
didn't happen so at some point I think a
jury could throw its hands up in the air
and say we don't know who to believe but
I guess the question for R Kelly is
should he go big or go home and it's
really his call depending on what his
endgame is and Terry Kelly is charged
with 13 counts in this case including
obstruction of justice tying back to the
2008 acquittal why do you think the
prosecution is focusing on that
particular charge
I think that charge is important because
obstruction of justice is very serious
when you intimidate a witness and they
don't get on that stand you are
affecting the system the justice system
in whole and you have to protect those
Witnesses they have to be able to come
forward if they're intimidated if
they're in fear of their lives the
system is not going to work so I think
the prosecution here wanted to make sure
that they sent a message and they did
with making that charge
thank you both thank you for joining us
here on Law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss Justice in
America
[Music]
foreign
[Music]